einmal reicht jetzt wegen der zelle mal
auf ich sage einfach doktor doktor motto
hast jetzt gerade die debatte über das
klug ski-club sterben in berlin neu
entfacht mit dem wunsch und der
bedingung der techno sollte
weltkulturerbe werden warum wir erleben
in berlin gerade eine ganz besondere
situation weil wir sehr viele investoren
haben die alle möglichen clubs
verdrängen weil sie sagen wir möchten
gerne auf dem grundstück bauen hier sind
wir gerade vom watergate das haus ist
auch an einen investor verkauft worden
und damit sind dann die mieten damit
wurden bei der vertrag ist ausgelaufen
und dann musste man die doppelte miete
dass sein und das ist eigentlich für
einen klub der kultur macht und musik
präsentiert und die leute wieder tanzen
wollen dazu eigentlich mehr finanzierbar
und das ist das hauptproblem der
clubszene gerade das ist eins der vielen
wir haben auch lautstärke probleme und
das alles trägt dazu bei dass am ende
die klubs verdrängt werden können
wie war das damals hast du angefangen
hast 1985 als dj rief dass da noch viel
besser und das war ja nicht als andere
situation da war ja die mauer immer noch
und wir haben uns dann halt halt clubs
gesucht wo es halt ging und ich wurde
eingeladen als dj aufzulegen und auch da
gab es den lärmbeschwerden und dann
könnten wir da nicht mehr weitermachen
und dann haben wir immer gesagt wir
machen unseren eigenen klub und sind
danach schöneberg und haben unseren
eigenen klub aufgebaut das war 1986 das
war die damalige probleme rosenheim und
was müsste sich jetzt konkret ändern
damit sich in den nächsten monaten und
jahren für die clubszene in berlin
wieder eine bessere situation ergibt
wir müssen alle zusammenkommen und
miteinander reden also politik und
behörden und die klubs wenn wir nicht
zusammenarbeiten dann finde ich auch
keine lösung über die situation bei wir
müssen neue
oder bessere bedingungen schaffen weil
die kosten einen clubs zu betreiben sind
sehr hoch das ist ja nicht nur die
mieter die man bezahlen muss aber man
hat ja auch leute die arbeiten müssen
bezahlt werden
die künstler die engagiert werden müssen
auch bezahlt werden dann hat man
versicherungen man hat einkäufe man hat
leute die da arbeiten
man hat gema zu bezahlen die
künstlersozialkasse und so weiter und so
weiter erhebliche kosten die man hat und
deshalb ist nicht so einfach einen club
zu führen
das heißt alle clubs in berlin stehen
gerade zusammen und versuchen das zu
ermöglichen
es gibt eine organisation die heißt die
klappe mission die gibt es in berlin und
die kümmert sich darum eine lobby zu
sein
gegenüber der politik um zu vermitteln
damit man halt bessere bedingungen
schafft wie das jetzt auch zb letzte
woche gewesen ist da gab's dann zb eine
aussprache im bundestag sogar okay das
heißt wir können hoffen
naja wenn man nichts tut dann wird sich
auch nichts also muss noch was tun damit
sich was tut und das ist jetzt die
richtige initiative und deshalb haben
wir von der gemeinnützigen gmbh die welt
gegründet hat mit dem namen the planet
jetzt auch eine initiative gestartet wir
wollen nämlich unsere kultur unsere
elektronische tanzmusik kultur als
immaterielles kulturerbe anmelden weil
es gibt zum beispiel auch schon
vergleiche oder auch zb beispiele dafür
die in der schweiz in zürich da ist die
techno gelebte kultur und das ist also
etwas was ganz ganz schönes weil wir
wollen dass auch weil das würde dann das
ganze noch mal von hinten noch mal
zusätzlich anschieben weil man könnte
dann damit zum beispiel auch die
regierungen verbessern bezüglich
gewerberecht mietrecht und auch
steuerrecht weil man könnte dann zu
sagen er an kontur club würde dann nur
noch sieben prozent steuern zahlen
man könnte auch zum beispiel wegen
den mieten recht könnte man auch sagen
auch da gibt es dann einen bieten deckel
war es gibt ja eigentlich keine nieten
deckel bei gewerbemieten und das ist
etwas was man auch dann diskutieren
könnte und auch einführen könnte um
letztendlich die kultur zu erhalten
eine gesellschaft ohne kultur ist keine
gesellschaft aber ist das nicht ein
etwas hoch gestecktes ziel diese idee
mit dem weltkulturerbe soweit ich weiß
ist dies beispielsweise auch keinen
weltkultur
das ist ja eine ganz andere situation
weil wir haben ja in dem techno haben
wir jetzt ja also in der elektronischen
tanzmusik kultur will ich mal sagen eine
ganz andere situation als wie bei jazz
man kann natürlich auch sagen klar ist
warum nicht wenn jemand eine idee hat
dafür und denkt das müsste man schützen
oder auch anerkennende als kulturen dann
sollte es jemand machen
wir haben uns jetzt spezialisiert weil
es auch meine kultur ist das anzumelden
um letztendlich die gute bedingungen zu
schaffen dafür dass das haus erhalten
bleibt weil wir machen das schon seit 30
jahren
und wir wollen es auch gerne weiter
machen und es ist nicht ganz unmöglich
weil wir haben schon gespräche geführt
mit der deutschen unesco büro und die
haben gesagt es gibt interesse auch
urbane kultur als im hotel das kultur
habe zu registrieren und anzuerkennen
und dann wird sich entscheiden ob es das
wert
das ist prozess dauert lang man muss
erstmal die ganzen fragen die da
gefordert werden beantworten das muss
halt dann wissenschaftlich begleitet
werden und wir haben sehr gute leute die
hier zusammen gekommen sind haben sie
sagen ja sie haben da bock drauf und
machen das kann bis zu fünf jahre dauern
ok dann wünschen wir viel glück da war
ein dankeschön
welche pläne